we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two David P I guess
something I must have at some point said
about smoking cigarettes led to the
following voicemail coming in recently
take a listen to it
hey David I wanna know
smokers as bad people because they don't
care why they get cancer or thank you
cancer that other folks with their
cigarettes well that's how I wonder no
David you have a great day there yeah I
don't think smokers as bad people I
really don't I think that smokers is
addicted people and I think that it's
it's an illness right it's you you've
got an addiction to something that is
terrible for you if you go back to the
process of how someone becomes addicted
initially there's nothing in there that
would indicate that we're dealing with
bad people I think that it's an issue of
addiction I think that if we were to
talk to smokers I I would assume that a
really small percentage would say I'm
indifferent to other people getting
cancer because of my smoking I think
most of them would say no that's not
what I want but we're dealing with
addiction here and I find it to be a
vile habit I hate being around it and I
do everything I can to if I'm walking on
the street when someone in front of me
lights up and they start kind of exuding
smoke like a chimney I will immediately
just move around them and get away
because I want nothing to do with it but
no I don't think smokers as bad people
on the bonus show today child sex
offenders are going to be named as such
in American passports what do we think
about that public health groups are in
favor of raising the smoking age to 21
years old nationwide what do we think
about that and another chris Christie
confrontation no ice cream cone involved
in this one but still an interesting one
nonetheless so all of those stories and
more on today's bonus show two ways to
get access to the bonus show number one
david pakman.com slash membership number
two patreon.com slash david pakman show
whichever you use and I encourage you to
use both by the way you can do both
we'll talk to you shortly on the bonus
show